the og crypto derivatives platform
and the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh fan show
i am very excited for this conversation today we
have so much to get through um obviously we're
talking all about bitcoin now before i kick this
show off i do want to say a massive thank you to
our sponsors bitmex because as always without them
we want to be able to bring you such important
content so a quick message from bitmex before
we bring our guest on so bit mex is the og crypto
derivatives exchange and now has a spot exchange
for you to buy and sell your crypto especially
in a bear market you need a name that you can
trust and bitmex sets the standard for reliability
performance and transparency it is proven itself
through multiple multiple market cycles and that
is very important because it has stood the test of
time we're seeing a lot of uh companies right now
go under so you need a company that you can trust
right now bitmex is actually celebrating the start
of bitmex spot with one million dollars in usd as
a prize so all you have to do to enter um users
just need to trade uh the crypto equivalent of 250
us dollars which means you know you could purchase
some bitcoin um you could purchase around 250 in
bitcoin now seems like a great time um and yeah
you can actually enter up to 25 times um to win
um and one lucky winner could actually get 500
000 us dollars in bitcoin so i'm gonna leave
all the information for you in the description
below if you are watching on youtube then you'll
just see it all in the description below bimx is a
great place so a huge thank you to them especially
because we talk about a lot of controversial
things on the show um and that's what we're gonna
get into now before i bring on my guest please if
you are watching on youtube don't forget to hit
the subscribe button so you never miss a video and
also hit the like button so you can support this
channel alright guys let's do this so joining
me today is the co-founder of looking glass it
is greg foss greg welcome to the show how are you
what a great time to be here thank you so much for
having me yeah it's great to see you uh we met a
couple of weeks ago um at the conference so before
you know we delve into this for those who don't
know you can you just give us your background
certainly um yeah it was great to meet
you at bitcoin miami um i am a 35-year
veteran of credit trading i earned my stripes in
the junk bond market starting on the sell side of
the street i worked for a canadian broker dealer
and then i moved to the hedge fund community
and lived the great financial crisis in the
hedge fund community i've experienced four
substantial financial crises in my life started
with the latin american debt crisis in 1988 and it
second crisis was long-term capital management the
third crisis was the great financial crisis 2008
and then the kobe crisis so i think i have some
you know let's call them work war scars and i i
what i bring to the table i'd like to say is 35
years of mistakes but i'm still alive i'm fighting
the good fight because you got to learn how to
manage your risk and that's what i like to think
i am i'm a uh i'm a credit risk manager or a risk
manager i'm so excited to speak to you four uh
four crises i can't even say that word uh full
crisis season it's gonna be pretty crazy um you
know the kobe crisis 2008 and everything else
that you mentioned um but before you know we
delve into this i am interested to know how
you first got into bitcoin well it's sort of
a neat you know it was a long process so i'm a
canadian but i completed two years of university
in the united states i got my mba at an ivy league
school called cornell university and while i had
the chance to work on wall street i decided i
wanted to come back to canada and i ended up
working for canada's largest financial institution
in 1988 and i was working directly for the cfo it
was a special projects group and i like to think
of myself as an engineer a financial engineer but
i did train in undergrad as an engineer so i was
in a restructuring in the royal bank of canada
and one of my projects the first projects was
working on the latin american debt restructuring
royal bank of canada was very similar to other
global banks they had lent way too much money to
lesser developed countries lbc countries of which
south america made up a huge component of that
and in 1988 u.s treasury secretary nicholas brady
proposed a plan to the global banking system to
restructure the debt of mexico it was the first
plan that turned out to be the first of many and i
was assigned the task of evaluating the brady plan
options and you know i did a quick back in the
envelope mathematical calculation and i realized
that the world bank of canada was technically
insolvent which is to say the book value of equity
of the royal bank of canada was vaporized if
the latin american debt portfolio was marked
to market now you'd think that the financial
analysts on wall street bay street would have
figured this out pretty quickly but they didn't
so you know i go in to see the cfo his name was
emil great guy and ago emil we have a problem
and he said i know don't tell anybody now as
the largest financial institution in canada
this was mind-blowing to me firstly that the
analysts didn't understand what was going on
secondly every equity shareholder of royal bank
of canada certainly had no idea what was going on
and most importantly i wasn't allowed to tell
anybody now not that i would have because you know
i'm a 25 year old kid what do i do run out to the
wall street journal and tell them that the global
banking system is insolvent clearly there was
a problem because that's why treasury secretary
nicholas brady proposed the restructuring
plan the point is over a 25-year period
of dealing with these restructurings i have
been exposed to what i call the fiat ponzi
okay now the fiat haunts you before you
explain the fiat ponzi are you able just
to speak a bit closer into your mic because the
background noise is coming through quite loud
um and i don't want people to miss this okay so
i am in an airport so i apologize so they think
you're doing the dishes greg they think you're
doing the dishes that's what i'm getting in the
comments come a little bit closer okay is that
better now a little bit um oh it's better when
you come closer when you come closer you know what
i might be on the wrong mic then i think i'm on
the wrong mic uh it should be going through my
headphones give me one second no okay no worries
all right we're gonna get greg's mic this is
settings okay no worries all right so we're going
to get greg's mic switch and then we're going to
find out about the fiat ponzi um which i think is
pretty important actually because a lot of people
right now um giving bitcoins prices down are
talking a lot about how bitcoin is a ponzi scheme
um which obviously we know isn't true um but they
they fail to hear how the fiat system is a ponzi
scheme so i'm really excited to get into this
are you able to switch it is that better
no can you count to 10 for us 10 9 8 7.
it's okay i can just we can just still
hear you but if you just speak louder
then hopefully you can overcome it okay give me
one more sec all right i'm gonna try one more
guys this is what happens when you do it live
this is this is is that oh that's better yes
let's go with that okay let's go with that okay
so yeah keep it close if you can okay so basically
the the problem with the fiat ponzi
starts with the commercial banking system
and the reason that's a problem is because
commercial banks are 25 times levered to
their capital base which is to say that for every
hundred dollars of loans a bank makes only four to
six dollars is equity capital or risk absorbing
capital and the other 94 to 96 dollars is
your depositor's money or subordinated debt
so how often do you think a bank makes a loan
and the value of that loan depo declines by more
than six dollars well it happens all the time
okay if you've ever traded debt which i've done
for 35 years you know that the prices of bonds
fall by far more than six dollars over
the economic cycle whether it's because
of credit risk primarily because of credit risk
or it's because of changing interest expectations
on behalf of the central banks globally
bond prices are volatile very simply leia
commercial banks need inflation in order
for their collateral to increase in value
to compensate for their under capitalization that
is the fiat ponzi in a nutshell after 35 years i
finally found bitcoin bitcoin is the only digital
asset that solves the fee of ponzi very simple
the thing which blows my mind is um the fact
that you know from your perspective you know
these people know that it's a ponzi right like
you were told not to say anything and and by the
way there was nothing coercive there um you know
it was it was a bit of a you know tongue-in-cheek
yes this is the commercial banking system but
the reality is henry ford said the same thing
about a hundred over a hundred years
ago right he quoted he was quoted as
saying if the average american understood
how the commercial banking system works
there'd be a revolution in the morning so you
know it's it's a fact of the structure of the
fiat system where you have commercial banks that
need to have an incredible amount of leverage to
earn proper returns for their equity holders it's
just it basically uh puts the system at risk of
cyclical failure and notice that the first
one 1988 was followed 10 years later 1998
was followed 10 years later 2008 was followed 10
years later 2020 okay the depths of these crises
get more severe because the central banks bail
out the system and kick the can down the road
and consequently we are in a spiral a debt
spiral that can never be repaid and thus
currency debasing is 100 certain would it be fair
to say that you believe it's destruction by design
heart i i can't go that far out on the limb
it's designed this way because it's always
been designed this way until there's an
alternative and that's why i'm so excited
about the parallel building a parallel network
that's built on uh different foundations totally
and you mentioned that 10-year cycle and then
we get to obviously covid um in 2020. so that's
one of the crisis which you mentioned how does
how is that comparable to the other previous
financial crisis you know like once financial
ones medical so can you explain the connection
yeah okay for sure i guess what i should have
said it was a financial crisis in the response
by the central bank so for example what
happened in 2020 that never happened before
was that the federal reserve said they would buy
high-yield bonds okay that was the first ever
in history that the fed came out and said they
would buy high-yield bonds why did they say that
very simply because there were four different
u.s based credits they are general electric
general motors ford and a t and t that were on the
cusp of being downgraded from investment grade a
subjective investment guideline for bondholders
from investment grade to high yield the combined
debt of those four companies is bigger than
the existing high yield market as a whole
so if they had been downgraded into the high yield
market and caused for selling by the investment
grade sellers that have to sell their bonds into
a high-yield market it would have overwhelmed the
high-yield market to the extent that it would have
caused a collapse of the equity market because the
equity got the bond guys rank as a prior claim in
the capital structure well guess what guys like
me do when you own a bunch of general electric
debt that is becoming more credit risky you go
out and you short the common stock so you see
how the cascade effect works through the system
and therefore the 2020 although it was a response
as you mentioned to a medical crisis the financial
crisis was more of the same uh-oh get involved
print money try and contain the contagion because
as high yield goes so goes equity markets
so what the fed was actually trying to do
was control volatility by back stopping the high
yield market okay and it worked to an extent it
regained confidence that's all it's about is the
confidence the liquidity of the system they don't
care so much with the prices as long as it still
moves meaning it trades what really happens in
every crisis is things gum up there's no trading
there's no liquidity things fall by literally
20 points 20 bond points which is a 20 drop in
the price of a bond let me tell you that's not
supposed to happen but bringing it right back to
the banking system if if a bond drops by 20 points
the same thing happens with the loan okay the two
things are peripassu meaning they rank exactly
the same in the credit strike structure for an
investment grade bond if general electric debt
fell by 20 points so did the bank loan and imagine
what happens with the bank loan that means all the
banks that only have six dollars of capital they
just lost twenty dollars uh-oh what does that mean
it means that the financial system is insolvent
again hence the fed backstop i hope i didn't
lose too many viewers here but you see how how
it's all contained within the leverage structure
of the of the banking system yeah no i appreciate
you um you know taking the time to explain that
no the viewers are going up it's all good we're
we're good um this is this is valuable knowledge
it's good to know um so you know what you're
talking about um in my opinion is um very it's a
very specific kind of knowledge that not a lot of
people um you know have um you know it's it's more
than being financially literate um and so that's
what you do right you educate people you promote
financial literacy yeah well we tried that yeah
when i sat in that risk chair there's nothing like
learning by uh trial by fire let's put it that way
you can study all the financial textbooks you want
and they'll talk about things like efficient
market theory and whatever let me tell you when
the world is melting down there is no efficient
markets there's like get me out i need to raise
money for my unit holders because i'm being uh
margin called i need to hit a bid i need to hit
some sort of liquidity bid and so you throw in a
liquidity bid that's like 20 points below where
the last bond traded and guess what you own them
and you're like oh my god i own these bonds down
20 points that means all the other bonds
that trade in that same industry need to be
marked down in lockstep because the credit risk
of the industry trades as a contagion type of uh
analysis so look all i will say is sitting in
a risk chair is a very important education and
i did that for 30 years and that's the biggest
problem i have with chairman powell he's a he is
a lawyer he has never sat in a risk chair he's
never felt well i have expressions and i won't
use them on your show you know the tightening
of certain body parts that uh that indicate
sitting in a wrist chair that you know you
certainly don't experience living in a classroom
you need to be in that chair understanding when
the market stops working and why it's so dangerous
yeah but the but you're the co-founder of
um looking gloss which basically looks to
inspire financial literacy teach financial
literacy right now that's a free platform
and that's because i wrote an article the genesis
of that was i wrote an article that basically
detailed my 30-year chris history in the credit
markets and it was submitted to bitcoin magazine
and it was quite well received and what happened
though there were a lot of readers that are like
oh my god i needed to open up a google doc to
see what foss was talking about the whole time
because i believe every single credit manager in
the world needs to own bitcoin as insurance on
the credit portfolio meaning on the fiat ponzi
okay so i wrote those thoughts in a uh in
an article what that's one of the reasons i got
invited to to speak at the first uh bitcoin miami
conference and it was well received but
it was written and i wrote it on purpose
for portfolio managers credit portfolio match
who were weird bunch okay we're a bunch of
square pegs in a round hole a lot of times you
know but at the end of the day they said can you
write it in layman's language and i partnered with
the group at looking glass education to do that we
did the first article again it was quite well
received and we said well why don't we do this
on a regular basis so really now i'm very proud
to be part of it but i am not the one running it
it's the two young men one from australia his name
is daz bay or b and he's a great kid uh you know
younger than me so he's a kid and then another one
from whistler british columbia who's a new zealand
expat who lives here in whistler that's where i
just got back from and the two of them are running
this education platform that here's i'm very
proud of it's been translated into eight different
languages and it's being used in el salvador
as the education platform in el salvador okay
so lots of really good stuff happening we just got
back from madeira for example and they're gonna
translate it into portuguese and use it in
the in the madeiran educational system etc so
yeah i'm a co-founder i guess you know but let me
be very clear i don't write specifically for that
anymore but the kids and when i say kids one
one's in his 30s and once in his 20s they're
doing an amazing amazing job of this and i'm very
proud to you know have been part of that for sure
well let's talk about financial literacy because
you know they don't talk about that in schools um
you know everything that you we've just mentioned
and i know you said it was only from experience
that you really understood about this fiat death
spiral um but why isn't it taught in schools and
also it's a great question let me we'll hit
that question first because if they taught you
that the fiat ponzi existed no one would deposit
their money in the commercial banks would they
they'd be like okay i'm teaching all these kids
through university that they shouldn't trust the
financial system oh my goodness that destroys
the fiat system itself so they can't teach you
and the places that we're seeing it catch on right
now are parts of the world that are non-g7 right
it's you know it's the g7 countries that run
the world they run the education system in
the g7 countries but you're seeing it actually
catch on in the less privileged countries of the
world where reality can be taught but you can't
learn this in britain all right as soon as they
taught you this in britain your your you know your
your famous bank street would go out of business
okay so you know make sure that we we know what
the incentives are to teach the truth and by
the way i went through six years of university
so four years of engineering and two years of
finance at in a business school in the usa and
trust me they absolutely don't teach you this
why well because it would mean that people would
question the viability and the sustainability of
the current financial system so let's bring
bitcoin into this how does bitcoin solve
everything that you've mentioned in a nutshell
from my perspective i believe bitcoin to be
credit insurance i believe it to be essentially
the equivalent of a credit default swap now i
don't want to get too granular with your listeners
but it's especially purchasing insurance on a
basket of fiat currencies and i can value that
using credit default swaps on sovereign nations
this is the gist of my thesis that bitcoin
should be thought of as credit insurance now
wall street has not agreed with that yet they've
decided they're going to trade it like a risk
asset and all the algos in in new york are going
to trade it in correlation to the s p and the
nasdaq but over time as big money becomes smarter
and it takes time for big money to be smart most
big money is stupid as a post okay including lots
of canadian pension funds that for example just
off the you know on the topic one large canadian
pension fund that invested in celsius network
seed capital round or series b before point this
is the mark a very foolish asset manager but the
reality is they exist all over the world these
types of asset managers who do traditional things
and don't study things that hard and they're
staffed by you know some old fat white guys
like me and at the end of the day they
are lazy they're intellectually lazy so
it takes time to to teach the world new tricks
and i believe it'll happen but right now there is
i believe that bitcoin should be inversely
correlated to risk markets meaning as equity
markets are tanking bitcoin should actually have
a bigger bid because it's insurance it's like
fire insurance and right now the fire is on
our back porch and the price of fire insurance
has actually gone down it's a beautiful thing it
doesn't make sense but not all markets make sense
so what is it about bitcoin's properties that make
it insurance again it's the anti-fiat okay so it's
it is essentially credit protection on the default
of a company excuse me a country and that's
exactly what it is now you know there's various
risk natures of countries around the world but
you would agree with me that argentina defaulting
for the fifth time in my career is not a really
good track record well people who live in
argentina should own insurance against that
regular regularly scheduled event in argentina
people in turkey should feel the same way but
believe it or not there is a credit default
swap market on the united states of america
which indicates there's people
that are betting on the possibility
of a default of the us treasury now that is not
as high likelihood but it's not a zero percent
likelihood either and the value of that credit
insurance requires that you have a counterparty
well the beautiful thing about bitcoin is there's
no counterparty risk and there is no time decay
bitcoin is actually the perfect insurance contract
because you know for example when i lived a great
financial crisis and i was short for example
owned protection on the default of a company
like lehman brothers now i never owned lehman
but just imagine i owned protection on lehman
and i owned it by bear stearns and all of
a sudden bear stearns is going down just
like lehman then i have to run out and buy
protection on bear stearns which was really
my protection on lehman you see how everything
cascades down and down and down so the beautiful
thing about the coin is an instrument that
in my opinion is the perfect financial option
to protect against the contagion in global
financial markets including country defaults
it's good saying this and i i do agree you know
on a long-term um sort of like a macro perspective
but right now you know bitcoins down and you know
inflation is up and you know everything that could
go wrong seems to be going wrong cost of living
everything and unfortunately you know people
and people look to bitcoin as that hedge against
inflation and apparently you know it hasn't really
performed for them right now so what would you
say to these people um you know who say really
how can it be you know this this insurance this
hedge um you know if this is the current state so
again for me it's not a hedge on inflation as
much as a hedge on global calamity but people
use the use that analogy that it's digital gold
and therefore they think that it has to be an
inflation hedge look what bitcoin is over the
long term will be a non-quarterly what's beautiful
in financial management a non-correlated
asset and people say well why is that the
case and very simply there is the uncertainty
because of the global debt spiral that fiat
oh i think you've cut out i don't know if
it's me or if it's you can you guys let
me know in the comments um whether it's
me or whether it's greg that's cut out
dude are we back though yeah did you cut up no
i i cut out as well i'm not sure if it was me or
i think it oh i think you're gone again greg
um guys can you let me know in the comments if
it's me or greg that's cut out um because i'm
not sure it's greg okay all right greg it's you
can you can you get better wi-fi for us give me
one sec okay all right let's see what we can do
all right thanks guys let's see
i think greg is changing his wi-fi all right
you're back how are you doing i'm not sure you
guys tell me i can hear you i can hear you yeah
okay so here my thought i apologize for this this
is the crappy canadian uh wi-fi in an airport but
uh nowhere he's gone again the only thing that's
a hundred percent certain in my analysis leia
is that fiat currencies will continue to debase on
an accelerated basis for that reason you need to
own protection against that now you could argue is
it an inflationary expectation well the truth is
even in a deflationary environment fiat currencies
will continue to debase so i don't care whether
it's inflation or deflation it's protection
against the certainty of fiat debasement that's a
very very important context because every
single fixed income instrument in the world
is a fiat contract so essentially you own a
contract that is guaranteed to debase in value
wow given that global debt is the largest
financial asset out there it's a certainty that
that financial asset will continue to debase over
time it blows my mind that people haven't done the
math but clearly a lot of people have not done
the math yeah i mean i'm not surprised because
you know people are um you know inspired to say
it not say it say no i don't think they're lazy
no i don't i think the average person
is inspired and encouraged to uh talk
about other things you know like uh race and
gender and sexuality and all of the all these
all these kind of like really irrelevant things
just really distract from the important stuff
like the fact that you're the money in your
pocket is losing value that's the way i look
at it okay that's true because not everybody can
be a financial engineer but not everyone can be
a social scientist not everyone can be an artist
or or whatnot but i guess at the end of the day
the biggest problem i have with this is that all
of us have children or will likely have children
we are pulling forward gains at the expense
of our children we are not paying our current
debts and our children will be the ones to bear
that price and i don't feel great about that
do you have um like a time frame for you
know when you sort of see um actually a
better question would be we can get to a time
frame a better question be like what kind of uh
shift do you see happening like when you know
what is bitcoin's role you know you talk about
this debt and the death spiral like when do
things change when do we see absolute collapse
one of the things about bitcoin or about trading
and financial markets and we just cut out
hopefully i'm back uh one of the things you never
make you can make a price prediction but not a
time okay so over time i know what price i believe
bitcoin goes to but i can't tell you when or it
would be foolish for me to predict an exa at an
exact time all i do know is these 10-year cycles
are getting more severe and they're getting
compressed more compressed so i would say
knock on wood i hope i live for the next 20
years i believe it will be within my lifetime
thank you for that i believe it'll be within my
lifetime i have talked about a price target i have
and it's a very rational price target in my
opinion which is over two million dollars u.s
per bitcoin in today's dollars is it 100 certainly
not in the slightest but the market is currently
pricing it at such a low probability that i'm
now i have the correct price target that i'm like
hey ship it in i think my odds are way better than
the odds that the market is giving me for that
potential outcome to come true it's interesting
so these 10-year cycles you know these different
crisis they are you said becoming worse and
closer together um so rather than waiting for 2030
you think like 2025 there's gonna be another kind
of difficulty going on sorry to ask um but yeah
yeah yeah you're i yes i do i think it's a high
likelihood but i can't say for sure but the bet
the smart money would say yes there is okay okay
and um so how how does bitcoin fix that though
like from a practical standpoint um because right
now it's still correlated and i know you said you
know wall street or whatever trading it like a
traditional stock and but right now it is still
correlated and it's been correlated for a while
right yeah so when does this decoupling research
well here i can't tell you but again it starts
with research like the research that was done
by fidelity now fidelity is a top five global
asset manager imagine if you're the other four
asset managers that compete with fidelity within
the top five and they offer a bitcoin silo
and the other four don't well any large asset
allocator has relationships with all four of those
at top oh all five of the top five it's not
hard for them to switch if they say hey well
i want to get this allocation with fidelity
and you guys aren't aren't uh offering that
i'm gonna switch all of my assets to fidelity
and blackrock will all of a sudden say
hold on don't go to fidelity do it with us because
we're going to offer this silo i've seen this
exist with high yield bonds that's where i got my
uh my start in canada 20 years ago there was zero
high-yield bond managers in canada now their
every single asset manager in canada offers a
high-yield bond silo because it makes sense so the
same thing will happen with bitcoin the same thing
will happen with these asset managers that are
kicking and screaming against this asset class
will have to embrace it because the clients
are demanding that they offer it and embrace it
in what way you know are we talking you
know bitcoin as the world reserve currency
we're talking about more countries adopting it
you know the bitcoin standard like specifically
what is that adoption it'll be a process
okay so let's talk asset management that
will be a a diversification strategy within the
asset management silos which include pension funds
university endowments uh mutual funds etfs
etc but then if you take it a level higher
one of the reasons they might want to get
involved is because they see countries like
el salvador doing what el salvador
did and bringing 44 other central bank
or central bankers from small countries albeit
but imagine if a country like canada my hometown
or home country decided to price bitcoin decided
to use bitcoin to price our oil and natural gas
whoa well i think it makes sense as an engineer
and once that happens the adoption continues
across the world now i'm not saying that canada
is going to do this but a smart sovereign nation
it is energy resource rich maybe russia for
example because they don't have a you know a
love on for the u.s petro dollar right now can
you imagine if they start pricing their energy
in bitcoin uh-oh and then the asset manager
say damn i gotta get me some of that because
i think bitcoin as digital energy not digital
gold so that's why i have a problem with the
inflation narrative so much like michael saylor
you know he's a really smart engineer i'm sort
of a i'm an okay engineer but we still understand
the law of conservation of energy and that's why
i love i love the bitcoin narrative so you see
how it all is correlated like you know you have
a country and then you have the asset manager and
then you have the individual investor down here
and it's all a process and it's you know it's only
13 years old we got to be careful like you know
it it's it takes time for these things to uh
percolate through the system damn i feel like
buying some bitcoin after this conversation i
mean if you're looking at canada and canada you
know it's about canada pricing things in uh don't
don't go there though because we're we're we have
a we currently have a ceo who's not the sharpest
tool in the shed okay so we got to be very yeah
we'll talk about that ceo in a minute um i have
some uh some questions you have a very strong
canadian accent um so i'm yeah well we'll
get into that um but before we do actually
um talk about uh trudeau the man himself um
i want to get your take on uh what is going
on bitcoin mining right now um i personally
am not fully up to date with all of that um
i know that there's been a lot of controversy
um you tweeted i'm gonna get it you wrote
if you are a bitcoin miner that does not
control your power you are in a [__] biz so
what does what does this mean what's the
controversy surrounding bitcoin mining right now i
wouldn't call it a controversy by any means i just
you know i tend to look at businesses uh as their
strengths and weaknesses and if you don't control
your input costs okay and you don't control your
output revenue because that's set by the market
that's a very difficult business so you're like
at the funnel of input right you have your energy
input you have your nozzle and then you have your
output which could be distribution it could be
all the things that set price on the on the top
of the funnel you're just this function in here
that if you don't control your power you can get
squeezed from both sides and that's exactly what's
happening right now in the bitcoin mining space so
i would argue and i'm involved in a company
in canada called validus power where we own
our power assets we own 400 megawatts of natural
gas-fired power plants we host some bitcoin miners
there but we own the power the miner doesn't own
the power now over time you just saw duke energy
for example a very large 50 gigawatt company
in the usa is studying bitcoin mining and how
oh you cut out again all right let's
hope we have hang on fluctuating
go back a second we missed you we missed you it's
okay duke energy go from duke energy we missed
you what happened to them yeah duke energy just
announced that they are uh studying bitcoin and
mining bitcoin using their power uh assets
the reason is because the the base load of
of uh of the grid fluctuates as people turn on air
conditioners when they come home from work then
they go to sleep well the generators keep turning
if you don't have demand for those generators you
wear out the generators and you can collapse the
grid so it's called base load management or base
load man balancing bitcoin mining is the perfect
insert into the base load management of any grid
you can increase your revenues you can turn
off the miners when you need to send the
power instead of to the miners you send it
to the grid and all of this builds a stronger
infrastructure anywhere in the world so again the
current publicly traded miners which is the nozzle
of the funnel they have to buy their power
from the utilities well that's not a great
business model in my opinion
over time i think that'll change
that's interesting because i mean i'm not super
technical like that um like my love and interest
for bitcoin comes from like a freedom standpoint
um so i didn't really know or understand the
difference between you know owning your own
power and you know what's been going on with
these companies who um are publicly traded and
people are buying their stocks because they
thought it was a good idea and now it's down
with everything else in the market well some
of them some of them do represent some good value
right now um having been in a distressed debt and
distressed asset trader my whole life things are
getting interesting uh in certain companies the
breakup value of the company is higher than the
implied stock price that's when i get excited as a
restructuring guy hey hey i can i can buy a dollar
for 65 cents i i like buying a dollar for 65 cents
yeah no i can imagine so um i wanted
to talk about canada um and i i want to
really just understand you know from your
perspective um how how the last two years been
you know i know there's been the lockdowns
you've had medicine mandates kind of um travel
restrictions and stuff like that um so just yeah
from your from your standpoint how's it been it's
been disappointing as a fifth year sorry a fifth
generation canadian whose uh grandad uh fought
in both world wars incidentally year bri year
uh in britain uh my my granddad was awarded the
order of the british empire in world war one in
world war ii for bravery in fighting for freedom
so i'm pretty uh you know it's near and dear to
my heart in the in the defense of freedom and
i think canada's uh in the last couple of years
has definitely gone in the wrong direction
this uh this whole response to the freedom
convoy in my opinion was a spoiled little brat
who is sitting in uh in office has lived off his
daddy's credit card his whole life and um his
response is typical of a uh you know a little bit
of a man who should not be in power uh you know i
i've said this before um i i'm open-minded i don't
believe bitcoin should be a political tool bitcoin
is a political but as far as the freedom goes
the freedom concept that you say you're very uh
close is near and dear to your heart i believe
the same thing and you know i don't if you had
asked me in the in the year 2019 so three years
ago if canada ever would have frozen bank accounts
within the next 20 years so between the year 2019
and 2039 hey foss what's your thought that canada
would would uh freeze bank accounts i would
say ah maybe 20 and guess what three years
later it's a hundred percent certain that
they would do it this is dangerous this is
not what my granddad fought for okay this is not
about you know this is a scared young very weak
ceo in power doing uh you know very child childish
things in my opinion you say ceo as if um he's a
independent weak scared actor you don't think he's
getting uh getting taking orders from somewhere
closer in europe i i i know that narrative and
i don't really want to go there but yes there's
that possibility isn't there um you know uh it
certainly seems like you can you can connect the
dots pretty easily but you know i got to be
careful here look i i have a lot of canadian
friends who you know we try and keep politics out
of this i'll just say again a fifth generation
canadian who uh you know who's literally whose
my ancestors came to canada before the us
declared independence okay just to give you an
idea of the history that it's there and it's it's
disappointing to see this happen because you know
like freedom is our is what keeps people doing
good stuff in my opinion so i i like to fight
for the same things that you like to fight for
and what's the narrative on the ground are people
happy with him um do people feel similar to you
you know i mean the the unfortunate circumstances
is he uh he won re-election with the minority
government again uh with less than 30 percent
of the popular vote uh but then he combined with
another uh another political party it's sort
of you know the canadian parliamentary system
is based on britain on the uk right there's a
lot of flaws in that and uh nonetheless uh you
know we have to deal with our own uh within the
constraints of our own political party so no the
you know six seventy percent of the population
did not vote for him as one way of looking at it
uh but that being said he's a minority
government for at least three more years
and how do you uh how do you feel about
canada in general like do you want to stay
do you feel um you know concerned that this
could happen again you know we spoke about
these 10-year cycles but looks like it could be
a five-year cycle these days um yeah like what
are your what are you probably prepping yeah i
i absolutely want to stay look i have three kids
who were born here uh they're not gonna leave in
the short term uh again five generations of uh
you know working to build a great country um i'd
like to think i'm not gonna cut bait and run um
you know i i do get over my skis sometimes uh you
know that whole tracker convoy thing was a little
pressure packed for uh for my uh my family um
but that being said you gotta stand up for what
you believe and uh this is a case of uh i believe
a concentration of power that's dangerous that's
happening globally too though late right it's
not it's not happening just in canada so agreed
yeah yeah it is happening globally um it's
those g7 countries as you mentioned um
and uh yeah i was talking to somebody today and
they asked me you know what do you think about
the future of bitcoin in terms of you know it
being banned and things like that and i said
you know not the whole world is on the same page i
mean you just know that from the reaction over the
last two years it's it's you know the people that
ask about it being banned or the people that you
know that love government almost they love this
they they're too weak to stand up for their own
uh rights they want government to protect them uh
in fact it's not those people that make countries
great okay what makes countries great in the case
of usa and uk and canada are the people that you
know that fight for the fight against what's wrong
and um you know i again i don't like to bring up
the the the past but my granddad was a very highly
decorated uh uh veteran of both world wars uh
you know he i still hear his voice in my head
sometimes like hey kid yeah like this is not
the right way for things to go down and um i see
some of that within the bitcoin community but
look what i need to say about the bitcoin
community and having met you in miami very briefly
but what i love about the bitcoin community is
they tend to be a community of givers not takers
okay everyone says oh they're in it in a get rich
quick squeeze it this is the furthest thing from a
get rich quick scheme that i've ever seen you have
guys like jeff booth one of the foremost thinkers
a personal friend of mine we just came back from
madeira uh a a trip to madeira visiting you know
the island and the president and whatnot this is
a community of thinkers that can change the world
and you know yourself and young women all over
the world that are getting involved in this i
i was in the city of vancouver last night with
a bitcoin meetup in vancouver 200 people just
came out you know to to hear me you know espouse
on my opinions on things i all i know again is
i've made 35 years of mistakes but i believe very
confidently that bitcoin is the best asymmetric
trade opportunity i have ever seen in 35 years
and when i say i bring 35 years of mistakes
i manage those mistakes i don't i'm not like peter
schiff i don't say oh bitcoin at ten dollars it's
a horrible deal don't ever buy bitcoin and then it
goes to seventy thousand and comes back to twenty
thousand he's like see i told you bitcoin was a
horrible deal what a loser okay i have to say that
time and time again the man is a horrible risk
manager and the fact that he continues to beat up
on an asset that's superior to his love of gold is
a mark of a man who is old and curmudgeonly and i
don't want to be that person as the information
changes i will change my investment policy
so once again manage your losers you sell your
losers and you keep your winners everybody
else tends to do the reverse learn to manage risk
people if you own zero bitcoin you are taking far
more risk than if you own i'm gonna throw out zero
to five percent so own five percent of bitcoin and
then don't focus on the price of bitcoin every
day you still have 95 of your portfolio and other
stuff that is more risky than the insurance policy
that's bitcoin it's very hard to get that through
people's heads okay they are human by nature they
focus on their winners okay and they sell their
winners rather than doing the opposite sell your
losers things like global bonds when global bonds
were negative yielding in europe that's not an
asset anymore that's a liability yet people still
put their money in assets that provided a negative
return what kind of foolish behavior is that
god knows these are a bunch of sheep running over
the cliff all at the same time yeah no it's said
really perfectly um i i saw a quote the other day
which was don't bother waking up the sheep wake
up the sleeping lions and i i like that a lot
yeah yeah i like that i don't agree with that
and and you know you've interviewed you know the
the the likes of michael saylor and perhaps you've
interviewed some people that are bitcoin haters
the the beautiful thing about bitcoin is it's an
education process i like to say it's an iq test
in risk management okay it's an iq test in risk
management and there's a lot of low iq risk
managers out there okay having lived in the pits
for 35 years trust me there is a lot of stupid
low iq money out there in the world absolutely
um greg you put that so eloquently um so i want
to thank you so much for coming on um where can
people follow you and follow your work i think
greg has frozen again at that very last second
let's wait till he comes out there we go i got
you okay sorry sorry i got you no you're okay
um i was just thanking you for uh putting
that so eloquently um and so simply and for
those you know who are still trying to learn
and understand um where can people follow you
and you know find out more about your work stay
up to date with everything that you're doing you
know if you're doing meetups whatever it is i'm
uh you know pretty old here so i only have one
social platform it's basically twitter uh you
can follow me on uh at foss greg foss so fos
oh we're we're we're gone again all right let's
see let's see if we can get greg back let's have
a look at that f-o-s-s we hear it now we hear
it now f-o-s-s g-r-e-g-f-o-s-s is my twitter
there we go and again all i know all i know is
see this iphone there's more power in this iphone
than put two men on the moon when i was alive
in 1969 that technology itself allows you
to hold the banking in your hand it will
change the world don't overthink this
it is the most beautiful financial technology
that i have ever seen please respect that if you
don't listen to people with experience in the pits
you are bound to recreate their errors like work
be smart i'll talk to you guys in 20 years okay
i look forward to uh the next time we can talk
perfect greg thank you so much i'm gonna let
you catch your flight i appreciate you coming on
and also thank you to everyone for watching um
please don't forget to hit the subscribe button
so you don't miss a video hit the like button and
so we can continue providing such amazing content
and also a massive thank you to bit max because
of course without them we wouldn't be able to
bring you such good content all right we'll see
you all next week bye bye today ohio plan show